another thing Dr bright is not allowed  to do with the foundation stop telling  people you're a wizard no matter what Dr  bright might tell you what kind of robes  he wears whether he has a pointy hat or  a walking stick or even a talking bird  on his shoulder he is not a wizard  speaking of birds Dr bright leave Dr  spenko alone he is not your familiar Dr  bright is not able to perform any spells  nor can he make potions aside from his  world famous Sherbert punch that he is  permitted to make but only for official  foundation holiday parties finally Stop  Standing in the doorways and declaring  you shall not pass sir Ian McKellen